bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à l'horreur on l'a vu
affrontements entre gangs armés et
forces de l'ordre notamment à l'armé
lourde
la puissance de feu des délinquants et à
ses impressions est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que certains délinquants
sont mieux armés que les forces de
l'ordre
oui je crois qu'il faut rappeler que
depuis plusieurs années le venezuela via
un contexte de guerre hybride avec
plusieurs fronts un froid
institutionnels un front diplomatique un
front médiatique au psychologique un
front économique avec le blocus est donc
un front militaire alors un front
militaire avec une multi sip les
multiplicités excusez-moi d'acteur vous
pouvez avoir des groupes de choc lié à
l'opposition la plus radicale
vous avez des déserteurs des forces de
sécurité vénézuélienne ou de l'armée
vous avez des paramilitaires notamment
en provenance de colombie puis vous avez
le crime organisé qui a changé de visage
depuis maintenant cinq ans et qui
dispute à l'état sa capacité
d'administrer le territoire et notamment
dans le contrôle des axes stratégiques
alors ça concerne pas seulement car à 15
ça concerne aussi des zones stratégie du
centre du pays avec des bandes armées
comme celle des traînes dalian ont
depuis cours et des traînes d'aragua qui
notamment essaie de mettre la main sur
les zones où passe la distribution
d'aliments ou des zones riches en
ressources naturelles ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui à caracas relève de la même
chose n'est-ce pas c'est à dire de la
tentative de certains groupes armés
alors dans le cas de caracas de ces
derniers jours c'est là la bande des
locaux qui n'en le basé sur le poids
stratégique qui relie caracas à sa
sortie ouest lakota novecento simcoe et
l'ensemble de ces groupes donc
e et c'est finalement ont des objectifs
aussi commun avec l'opposition la plus
radicale notamment d'essayer de faire
croire que le venezuela est un état
failli je pense que ce n'est pas un
hasard que l'offensive de la bande des
locaux qui est débutée le même jour de
l'arrivée de la mission exploratrice de
l'union européenne pour envoyer des
observateurs aux élections de novembre
on va en parler dans quelques instants
pour revenir à ce qui s'est passé là à
caracas
est ce que ces quartiers populaires de
la capitale sont livrés depuis trop
longtemps aux trafiquants de drogue aux
bandits ou est ce que on peut dire que
le gouvernement maîtrise finalement la
situation
ils ont que comme vous l'avez aussi
mentionné il dispose d'un arsenal
militaire gigantesque un l'aller la
quantité d'armes qui a été saisie des
lance-roquettes des plusieurs armes de
guerre alors je précise la plus grande
quantité d'armes de guerre saisis ne
provient pas de l'arsenal qu'utilise la
police ou l'armée vénézuélienne on a
trouvé énormément de ar 15 2 barrettes
m4e 22 qui sont des armes étasunienne et
dont la provenance
pour l'instant fait beau ce question
le l'état est en guerre contre ces
groupes pour récupérer la
l'administration total de son territoire
et puis aussi pour délivrer les
populations civiles
un prise en otage par ces gangs dans ces
quartiers populaires oui parce qu'on va
le rappeler en au venezuela on a donc un
président élu en nicolás maduro qui
n'est pas reconnu par une partie de la
communauté internationale en tête de
liste on a bien sûr les états unis 1 et
joe biden l'a d'ailleurs redit ans le 5
juillet pour lui le président c'est juan
wade au les sanctions économiques et les
pressions diplomatiques se multiplient
pour quelles raisons joe biden qui
intime temps au départ de nicolás maduro
alors le évidemment ça la fable des des
deux présidences ne tient pas dès qu'on
franchit les frontières du venezuela
juan garrido n'a aucun poids sur aucune
institution sur l'ensemble du pays le
contrôle absolument rien dès que nous
sommes au venezuela évidemment là cette
question de pose aucun doute le
président élu légitime légale c'est
nicholas maduro
je crois qu'il y à il ya un an je dirais
un effet de deux de carotte et bâton je
crois qu'il faut essayer de bien
déchiffrer ce qui se dit à washington
car il y à des élections donc régionales
et municipales en novembre et je pense
que ces élections vont être l'occasion
d'une sortie par le haut de plusieurs
puissances étrangères au premier lieu le
l'empiré étasunien et ses satellites
européens ou latino américains de
trouver une
une sortie digne de l'opération gouaille
taux enclenchée par donald trump il ya
maintenant deux ans donc on est un peu
dans une sorte de négociation qui avec
elle même
ramène aussi des moyens de pression de
divers types pour pouvoir peser dans ces
négociations dans cette sortie de 2,2
d'offensive institutionnels justement
quel point les sanctions économiques
parce qu'il faut le rappeler le
venezuela est sous sanctions économiques
à quel point ces sanctions et toof
l'économie du pays
écoutez c'est dramatique un leurre plus
que de sanctions il s'agit en réalité
d'un blocus de mesures coercitives
unilatérales prises par les états unis
et qui menace
évidemment le venezuela mais aussi
toutes les entreprises privées
étrangères qui ne peuvent pas commercer
avec le gouvernement vénézuélien donc
c'est à dire empêcher le venezuela
d'exporter son pétrole qui est sa
première source de revenus je rappelle
que avant le blocus 95% des devises du
venezuela provenaient de la vente de
pétrole
et puis il ya aussi les impairs les
importations notamment d'aliments de
produits de première nécessité de pièces
de rechange pour les industries
électriques pour l'eau pour l'industrie
pétrolière mais aussi des produits
pharmaceutiques voir des vaccins nous
l'avons vu il ya quelques quelques jours
ou kovacs n'a à livrer les vaccins à au
venezuela en dépit du fait que le
venezuela est payé ces vaccins donc le
blocus av est une technique utilisée
aussi dans d'autres pays pour étouffer
la population faisant le pari que celle
ci se retourne contre les autorités
légitimes du pays
ainsi visés romain miguet ce merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
fondateur du site francophone
d'actualité de l'amérique latine les
deux rives mercière